[Música]
bienvenidos a una emisión de reporteros
gracias por estar con nosotros
comenzamos
la historia de hoy es en el cáucaso y el
asomo de una nueva disputa territorial
entre armenia y azerbayán justamente
este último país sobre la base de su
abrumadora victoria por el enclave de
nagorno karabaj a finales del año 2020
contra las fuerzas armenias y que dejó
al menos 3.000 muertos está aprovechando
ahora su ventaja y rediseñando
unilateralmente parte de su nueva
frontera con armenia desde ereván se
dice que los soldados azeríes están
interesados en las regiones fronterizas
de su nick y cunit una situación que
hace entrar en pánico al niño
especialmente a los habitantes de los
pueblos fronterizos lo que podría abrir
una nueva herida entre armenios y
aceites
[Música]
sur no en la región de su nick en el
centro de armenia a la entrada del
pueblo un cartel escrito en láser y da
la bienvenida a los visitantes
sobre esta carretera el lado izquierdo
está controlado por azerbaiyán y el
derecho por armenia en el medio los
soldados rusos actúan como mediadores
una situación que sume a los aldeanos
armenios en el desconcierto
anahí de 71 años perdió su casa está
viviendo temporalmente aquí en
condiciones insalubres
en
masa
es una luz
epstein malvín
rivero
esta casa se la prestaron a na y solo
tiene unas pocas propiedades allí
recibe ayuda del gobierno y pronto se
trasladará a las alturas del pueblo
le resulta difícil aceptar esta nueva
realidad
h
desde la última guerra de cara baja y la
toma de muchos territorios por parte de
azerbaiyán el ejercito azerbayano ha
llegado a las puertas de armenia y ahora
cuestiona sus fronteras
el alcalde de sur no explica cómo su
pueblo fue cortado en dos
12 familias armenias se quedaron sin
hogar
siento mucho dolor mi casa también se
quedó en el otro lado es difícil
[Música]
se le impuso una nueva frontera de facto
trazada unilateralmente por vacuno
al azerbayano dijo que no le interesaba
ningún mapa sino sólo el gps que tenía
en la mano
y dijo que todo se decidía con eso
no le interesaba ningún mapa de todos
estas tierras deben ser devueltas en la
república de armenia
es decir no sé pero tengo la esperanza
de que se produzca
la línea fronteriza cambió varias veces
durante la era soviética
una delimitación puramente
administrativa en su momento pero desde
la caída de la unión soviética armenia y
azerbaiyán se disputan varios
territorios cada uno basado en mapas
contradictorios
hoy
así que la frontera está ahí
ese es el mapa real en su gps cortaron
este campo en dos y llegaron a este
camino en la parte alta
algunos huertos y cortaron la última
casa entonces el célebre señor es
ver si tu parte nos pertenece la otra la
tomaron dos y extender esta vamos a ver
ceder
y esta es la casa un recorte
potencialmente explosivo del pueblo de
su nook es emblemático pero muchos otros
lugares de su nick están amenazados
[Música]
nos vamos a tener quien cóndores donde
la vida de los habitantes ha cambiado
radicalmente
[Música]
zúrich un voluntario nos lleva a las
afueras del pueblo desde ahí vigila a
los soldados azerbaiyanos apostados en
la colina de enfrente
yo sé
que el
pueblo está rodeado ellos están por allá
por allá también
el pueblo es como una isla en el medio
por caminos que tomaron es el único que
nos pertenece
consecuencia de la presencia de los
azerbayanos la pérdida de muchas tierras
de cultivos pastizales y cabezas de
ganado que accidentalmente cruzan al
otro lado
muchos aldeanos ven amenazada su
existencia de nuestras tierras
raúl ya no oculta su preocupación
y
vemos a los soldados entrar y salir todo
el tiempo podemos verlos desde aquí
antes los niños bajaban al valle a
recoger flores pero ahora no no los dejo
ir y no van solos
y nos quedaremos aquí esta es nuestra
tierra nuestro país
[Música]
ante el aumento de las tensiones
fronterizas el ejército ruso se ha
desplegado en su único
el objetivo evitar cualquier escalada
la presencia de soldados rusos es
tranquilizadora en la región
tenemos que expresar nuestra gratitud a
la federación rusa por ayudarnos y estar
a nuestro lado
todo está bien en materia de defensa
nuestro ejército está vigilando si es
necesario podemos resolver los problemas
sin embargo armenia salió debilitada de
la guerra de carabajo y firmó un acuerdo
de alto el fuego muy desfavorable la
superioridad militar de bakú no está en
duda y la mala jeff está multiplicando
sus reivindicaciones territoriales entre
otros sobre el sonic al que llama el
sangre sur
cada baja sangre sur son nuestras
tierras históricas las tierras de
nuestros antepasados
desde mayo azerbayán ha incrementado sus
incursiones en territorio armenio
objetivo presionar al gobierno armenio
para que haga concesiones en particular
la puesta en marcha de un corredor que
uniría a azerbayán con su enclave de
maquillaban y por tanto con turquía
ante esta situación algunos armenios
decidieron alistarse para defender la
frontera de su país
en este campo de entrenamiento los
voluntarios muestran su determinación
es una cuestión de supervivencia
no una cuestión política
es ser o no ser
yo día o noche
otras ventanas
starting para atrás tech
hoy
estos voluntarios están convencidos de
que sólo pueden confiar en sí mismos
garner ámbos hold los reds
en el momento del genocidio armenio el
mundo entero guardó silencio
en 2020 con esta guerra en caravaca el
mundo entero ha vuelto a caer
este silencio obliga al pueblo de
armenia a darse cuenta de que la guerra
no está lejos
algunos de los participantes en el
ejercicio serán destinados a las
fronteras al día siguiente
en la región del arco único abundan los
incidentes fronterizos
varios soldados armenios fueron
asesinados otros fueron secuestrados
el pasado mes de junio fuimos testigos
de la liberación de uno de ellos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
un efímero momento de alegría a pesar de
un contexto amargo
a 10 km la vida cotidiana de los
habitantes se ha vuelto insoportable
el ahora ex soldado que fue liberado
durante nuestra estancia testificó
[Música]
los azerbayanos siguen disparando a las
casas
robando ganado quemando campos de hierba
seca
lanzando neumáticos en llamas hacia el
territorio armenio
y continúa hay nuevos actos maliciosos
cada día
armen mudayyan planea dejar armenia para
dar a sus hijos un futuro lejos de la
guerra
y pre markarián ha abandonado el campo
de entrenamiento ahora entrena a los
reservistas del ejército
para muchos armenios el futuro es más
incierto que nunca
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de reporteros recuerde que puede
ingresar a nuestra página web las 24
punto com para ver esta y las anteriores
hasta la próxima semana
[Música]